I think I heard you say once that it's
uh did I answer a single one of your
questions no but that's not the point of
this are you sure yeah I was I was I was
no no you're doing very well homeless I
was anxious no no but we you know this
is this is my method okay and this is my
way of helping you okay by not answering
the questions you're answering the
ultimate question wow that's a
trip man yeah yeah I own that quote now
hashtag Conan wrote that
um you're Howard Stern's favorite
interview that's gotta feel good it does
feel good that's gotta be that would be
my oscar that'd be on an Oscar
um I'd still I'd prefer the Oscars
because if I had an Oscar you know what
I would do I would I would have it uh
bolted to the hood of my car no way
people always act kind of coy like oh no
one's at home or it's in the broom
closet no I would have it mounted on the
uh on the on the hood of my car and
drive around and then act surprised when
people notice it if I had a cable Ace
award I would be doing that I would duct
tape it to the front I love that you
even know what a cable Ace award is I
came up through the cable Ace Awards
cable Ace Awards raised me
shape my world view brother let me
explain to our listeners
and doesn't know what a cable Ace is but
a long time ago they had a separate
award show for cable and it was really
looked down on like now HBO just gets
the Emmy like anyone else yeah yeah but
back then it was the cable Ace Awards
and when I first got to La I I was
nominated for a cable Ace award and I
went to a cable Ace award show and it
was my introduction to the world because
I was working on an HBO show but it was
back when you got HBO uh at a you know
like I want to watch HBO let's go find a
motel and check into it
but um I went to a cable Ace Awards and
just and I've never been to an award
show before I'm 22. I'm from uh Boston
by way of Ireland and Lebanon and I'm
excited and I I'm sitting in the in the
audience and someone came out with a
headset and a clipboard and said ladies
and gentlemen uh the top of the show
there were group The Temptations are
going to come out or the Four Tops yeah
I forget which but let's say it's the
Four Tops The Four Tops are gonna come
out they're going to sing a medley of
their hits they'll be dressed to space
man
they will have uh pretend laser guns the
lasers will be added later in special
effects when they all in unison point a
laser
all of you please go ooh as if a laser
has been fired
thank you very much
and I was like what and then ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the koa's awards
1985. it's the Four Tops
kazoo and we all went
sugar pie you don't want to be causing
wow
and I thought oh show businesses
complete embarrassing
it's the most embarrassing I I wish I
was an attorney I wish I was a tax
attorney who worked in a big office
tower I'm just as sad for everybody
insane yeah that was the cable Ace
Awards and so how could you're so much
younger than me how do you eat that's
not true yes it is true you are 20 years
younger than me no I don't believe that
okay well I know I look amazing I mean I
look amazing can you tell people
can't see right now but I'm not wearing
a shirt and my chest is oiled
that's uh you should be like my eyes are
up here honey
um
you know what would be fun is it just
occurred to me right now and it's and
this is more in your territory but if
people if I could figure out a way that
people didn't recognize me but I went to
uh bodybuilding competition but with my
body but we oiled it up and I wore the I
wore the like you know really small
bathing suit and I just come out and I'm
flexing and it's not that I'm
just with people boo no way we need it
up no they would eat it up no but I've
done no I've done I've done yeah but you
take a Viagra so you're pitching a 10.
give people a little show you know what
I mean